The post-credit scene has become one of the
hallmark features of the MCU — which isn't
surprising, since every instalment in the
franchise has at least one.
But these sequences do more than just advertise
future Marvel movies.
Here's why the post-credit scenes are the
best part of the MCU.
Marvel uses their end-credit scenes for a
number of different purposes.
Some, of course, are serious and somber — but
one of the best uses for a good end-credit
clip is as a humor-laced palette cleanser.
For obvious reasons, superhero flicks typically
go high-stakes during the third act, and that
means things can get pretty serious pretty
quick.
Villains make bold moves, heroes overcome
their personal shortcomings, and the action
gets cranked up to 11.
A post-credit scene is an ideal way to keep
things light as the story wraps up.
For example, a quick trip to the Shawarma
Palace was the perfect way to ease the tension-filled
final act of The Avengers.
Bruce Banner's role as a sleepy therapist
played off nicely against Tony Stark's weighty
self-revelations in Iron Man 3.
Even in a more comedic movie like Guardians
of the Galaxy, the sapling Groot's sneaky
jive to "I Want You Back" just keeps the good
times rolling.
There are many other, often more serious,
reasons that the MCU's arsenal of post-credit
scenes are counted among the best parts of
these films.
And yet, even if there was literally no narrative
substance to be found in them, their comedic
nature alone would still make them invaluable
additions to the MCU canon.
The end of a movie is typically meant to bring
a sense of clarity and closure.
Storylines are wrapped up, mysteries are solved,
and a sense of normalcy tends to be restored.
However, when it comes to a serial universe
like the MCU, everyone already knows that
the tranquility is only temporary and, often,
circumstantial.
This is where post-credit scenes come in to
pack a punch — by relentlessly stirring
up a constant sense of uncertainty for the
future.
As much as viewers might want to rest easy
knowing that Peter Parker put Adrian Toomes
behind bars, the villain's post-credit run-in
with Mac Gargan shows that Spidey's duel with
Vulture is anything but over.
Meanwhile, Stephen Strange's morbid time loop
with Dormammu may have ended well for the
Master of the Mystic Arts.
But Mordo's subsequent appearance as a villain-in-the-making
ensures that the good doctor's work in his
titular franchise is far from complete.
Heck, even in a film like Infinity War, which
ends on a cliffhanger, the post-credit scene
with Nick Fury's pager still manages to throw
in one last dash of tension.
And then you've got J. Jonah Jameson's Far
From Home appearance, which raises about a
million questions at once.
All in all, one of the best ways that post-credit
scenes bring the heat is by regularly disrupting
the traditional concept of the "happy ending"
— and leaving audiences clamoring for more.
Considering they exist in a detached form
at the tail-end of a movie, post-credit scenes
manage to get a lot of stuff done in a very
short amount of time.
Take the new characters they introduce, for
example.
When you look back over the years, there are
a ton of MCU favorites who interrupted a wall
of credits to make their first appearances.
Nick Fury kicked the introductions off way
back at the MCU's genesis by popping up in
the final moments of Iron Man.
Fans also met Wanda and Pietro Maximoff for
the first time at the end of Captain America:
The Winter Soldier, and Howard the Duck even
makes his first appearance in the Collector's
trashed museum at the end of Guardians of
the Galaxy.
Sometimes the "introduction" comes with more
of a hint, though.
Thor is preceded by Mjolnir at the end of
Iron Man 2, the long-awaited Adam Warlock
is strongly hinted at in a post-credit scene
for Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2, and of
course, Captain Marvel is headed off by her
famous symbol glowing on Nick Fury's pager
at the end of Infinity War.
Whether it's the character themselves or a
blatant hint at their impending arrival, however,
Marvel uses their post-credit scenes to introduce
characters early and often throughout the
MCU.
There's no doubt that each and every MCU film
has to juggle a lot of content.
Multiple character arcs, storylines, and crossovers
must all be addressed in just a couple of
hours.
This inevitably leaves countless ends loose
and questions unanswered as each story marches
towards its conclusion.
With the larger interconnectedness of the
MCU to fall back on, these hints often aren't
addressed until later films.
However, at times, the writers and directors
take advantage of the humble post-credit scene
to fill in some gaps, answer questions, and
occasionally even provide a big reveal or
two that never made it into the movie itself.
Take, for instance, Erik Selvig's scene at
the end of Thor.
With Odin back on the throne and peace apparently
restored to the Nine Realms, everything seems
hunky-dory in the son of Odin's world — except
for the little detail that Loki is using mind
control to manipulate Selvig.
The big reveal sets up the first Avengers
film, of course, which follows two installments
later.
Similar big reveals take place when Nick Fury
first brings up the Avengers Initiative in
Iron Man, Cap and Falcon detain Bucky at the
end of Ant-Man, and Wakanda finally gets some
real screen time in the final moments of Captain
America: Civil War.
While many post-credit scenes are fairly forward-thinking,
occasionally, they serve as little more than
a dramatic flourish for the job-well-done-of-a-movie
that preceded them.
The Guardians of the Galaxy franchise is particularly
good at pulling off these quirky embellishments.
These movies consistently tapped into a variety
of entertaining credit scenes that feel like
nothing so much as a humorous bow at the end
of a successful third act.
Baby Groot secretly dancing when Drax isn't
looking, Kraglin stabbing Drax with Yondu's
Arrow, and Peter Quill checking in on Adolescent
Groot to criticize the state of his bedroom
are all perfect codas to their respective
movies.
They don't make grand gestures or reveal massive
new pieces of information.
They're just plain fun.
These kinds of scenes show up in other MCU
films, too.
Captain America pops in for a quick public
service announcement at the end of Spider-Man:
Homecoming.
Thor pays Jane Foster a visit at the end of
Thor: The Dark World.
The team nabs a quick bite to eat at the end
of The Avengers.
In all of these cases, the post-credit scenes
don't necessarily bring much in the way of
new info or future teases, but that doesn't
change the fact that they're pretty darn entertaining
all the same.
One of the best ways that post-credit scenes
shine is simply by keeping the MCU freight
train rolling along.
This is true whether a movie has an open-ended
resolution or wraps up in a neat and tidy
manner.
In these cases, the post-credit scenes take
the audience by the shoulders, turn them in
a specific direction, and explicitly demonstrate
where the story is going next.
Little hints of information, like Bucky checking
out his past at the end of The Winter Soldier
or Hope van Dyne being shown the Wasp suit
in Ant-Man's post-credit scene, are loaded
with possibility, but they don't actually
tell the viewer much.
Meanwhile, post-credit scenes are often called
in to save the day by restoring a sense of
hope for the fans.
Sometimes this is a direct counterstroke to
a devastating development, such as Nick Fury
paging Captain Marvel in the wake of Thanos'
snap, or Bucky being sent back into cryostasis
in Wakanda in order to finally find some rest
and healing.
His future post-credit scene in Black Panther
also sowed the seeds of hope — that Bucky
would eventually find his place as a hero
in the Marvel universe.
All this typically sets the internet forums
ablaze and gives podcasters and YouTubers
hours of juicy content, as they endlessly
rehash each scene and theorize about what
might happen next.
Essentially, these scenes whet everyone's
appetites, prepare them for the future, and
keep them coming back for more — time and
time again.
The Mad Titan is a big deal in the world of
MCU post-credit scenes.
After all, the villain practically lives on
the murky edges of the franchise for nearly
the entire first three quarters of the Infinity
Saga.
Thanos' impending yet reticent off-screen
approach was dimly felt for years, as the
Infinity Stones were slowly revealed one by
one, and the storylines for Infinity War and
Endgame were gradually teed up.
He plays a minor role in Guardians of the
Galaxy, sure, but apart from that, he only
appears twice before his full unveiling in
Infinity War.
Where does he make these appearances, you
ask?
Why, in two post-credit sequences, of course.
The Mad Titan first appeared at the end of
The Avengers, where he smiles at the thought
that challenging Earth's heroes would be courting
death — a shoutout to his morbidly romantic
comic book origins.
He then appears once more in the middle of
the credits for Avengers: Age of Ultron, at
which point he dons the Infinity Gauntlet
and decides to take matters into his own hands.
While plenty of characters get their introductions
in post-credit sequences, Thanos alone can
claim that he was literally developed by them
for years — before he finally was unleashed
to wreak havoc on the main narrative itself.
The Infinity Stones are a central part of
the MCU.
This is especially true for the first three
phases that make up the Infinity Saga, which,
obviously, is literally named after them.
The Tesseract shapes the stories of both Captain
Marvel and Captain America.
The Power Stone is a central focal point for
the first Guardians film.
The Mind Stone impacts the first two Avengers
movies and gives us Scarlet Witch, Quicksilver,
and Vision.
The Aether also tampers with Thor's storyline,
and Doctor Strange would never have achieved
greatness without the help of the Eye of Agamotto.
While most of the Infinity Stone storylines
take place in the main movies, though, the
post-credit scenes do help fill in some pretty
important points in their collective story.
The Tesseract's narrative thread goes right
through both Goose's upchucking credit scene
in Captain Marvel to Erik Selvig's post-credit
scene in Thor.
The Aether finds its way into the hands of
the Collector in his scene from Thor: The
Dark World, and Wolfgang von Strucker's experiments
with the Mind Stone are first shown at the
end of The Winter Soldier.
No matter which way you slice it, post-credit
scenes played a pivotal part in the Stones'
journeys throughout the Infinity Saga — and
it's fair to say they'll have a role to play
in MCU's next saga, too.
Post-credit scenes are occasionally used to
provide a sense of closure that may have been
missing during the actual movie.
For example, a good portion of Thor: Ragnarok
takes place on Sakaar, where Thor meets the
villainous Grandmaster and his cronies.
Eventually, the newly-formed Revengers high-tail
it off the garbage planet, leaving a fledgling
rebellion in their wake.
The movie itself doesn't show how that rebellion
plays out, though the audience is given a
quick glimpse of Sakaar's fate when a post-credit
scene shows the Grandmaster cornered by rebels.
Black Panther also ties up loose ends during
the credits, when a scene shows T'Challa informing
the United Nations that Wakanda will be opening
up its borders — a theme that was brought
up more than once throughout the film.
Sometimes this closure is far more subtle,
though.
For instance, Avengers: Endgame famously lacked
a post-credit scene, opting instead to play
a few seconds of audio — that sounded an
awful lot like a final homage to Tony Stark,
hammering away on his Iron Man armor.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.